it's like almost like everybody wants
like hopes that you have a miserable
experience you know like they're trying
to be nice but they're like
you just wait and wait till the baby
gets here yeah and you're gonna then
you're gonna see your life's gonna
change you know it's fun but
you just wait you know and it's like
i'm like do you want me to like be
miserable or
is it because i feel like this is
supposed to be awesome you know
so we'll see i guess maybe i'll be doing
that to people in a year from now you
know yeah yeah depends on how much sleep
you get the first year then you'll be
the one to give
i advice like the country music scene is
a tight-knit community you know you have
a lot of celebrity friends who would you
trust the most to be the best babysitter
oh jeez man that's a loaded question
um man i probably no one to be
completely honest with you
no one yeah no one
but when it comes to his friend ed
sheeran well there's no one else luke
would rather share a stage with oh man
he's super great you know super down to
earth dude and just being insanely
talented from you know songwriter singer
performer but yeah me and him have kind
of gotten to know each other over the
years and see a lot of myself in him
personality wise
hopefully these two superstars team up
again perhaps on luke's forthcoming
album growing up which features this new
single tomorrow me
i think the focus of that song is not
necessarily
what's going on in my life at the time
but there are millions of other people
who have been there